just scraggly triangle head on top of a
praying mantis body I mean I guess my
name is first off ik if you don't know
now you know your life is different now
under-eye circles
/ bags we hate it disgusting you are a
sign of weakness
sign them you're not okay that's okay
earlier today I saw this tweet from
cosmopolitan because for some reason I
follow them on Twitter toriel asbestos
cover up your under-eye circles that
girl looks so sad with a river of cheese
and meat grease running down her face
but she doesn't look tired I've never
seen some like this before and I doubt
super cool but I want to try and
recreate this to see if this is easy or
difficult I have a feeling it's the
latter shoot no wonder I'm so tired I am
tiring and then I want to expand it and
see what else we could do under our eyes
to cover up our under-eye bags let's do
this let's share it with some peeps
under our eyes
I have faith thing you're obviously a
very good artist or whoever did this is
a good artist I'm gonna do my own
interpretation of that Ryan pizza river
also what I call my digest just I'm
gonna start with yellow give me do you
look at me do you look at me the yellow
thank you don't eat it maybe
Messi's water on this what I do with
this where's the label Hey water mother
I just put some water in a tiny Moscow
Mule a little shot glass because I'm a
role model Pizza you just twirl it like
this oh we go well like years and ruber
protip always do a Robert DeNiro
impression when you're covering up your
under-eye circles because it tightens
the skin and you can cover more welcome
okay try other one what's your favorite
type of pizza I don't give em any others
of you out there cry pizzas not out of
there under eyes without other butthole
because they're also lactose sensitive
like maybe but in the comments down
below
long hair cheese tears are done which is
a fun nickname for a sorority we're
gonna let the yellow dry a little bit
and then we're going with red and create
our pepperoni okay it's kind of dry I
can't I'm impatient so let's move on to
you pepperoni just put some red circles
in and you
shred it then we put pepperonis on her
face by ourselves on a Friday afternoon
as a 31 year old woman who graduated
from college our tape it's always great
to cover up the imperfections on your
face by drawing giant red blotches on oh
my god well otherwise whoa I would slap
meat on my face that fast and like two
hours and I know we're gonna let this
dry a little bit and I'm going to take a
black liquid liner we're going to draw
in some details
makalah 2018 is coming this woman seems
to just kind of outlined everything even
drawn in some detail so I'm just going
to sort of do my best finish this is
very Coachella in a Papa John's is for
that that's all the makeup brand deals
that are currently flooding into my
inbox right now oh wow my art teacher in
elementary school really did not give me
the encouragement that I should have
gotten the other one oh woah-oh woah-oh
wallah
pizza bag I tried to add some white
shaving when she has but then it didn't
go well so I stopped and I thought we've
gone far enough it's okay it doesn't
have to be perfect because it's never
going to be perfect
you're drunk pieces under your eyes at
your job I don't look tired anymore do I
just look super desperate for attention
this isn't a really great start but now
I'm gonna try some other options that
you might be inspired by in case you
don't want to drop it because you're a
monster do it here are some other
under-eye bags
cover-up option now tea bag barf bag
stick bag fun bag
garbage bag douche bag trash bag come
back back well there you go guys
even just drawing a face on my faces
know your music whatever you go guys
there is my work there is my attempt at
making pizza bags and some other
hopefully inspirational bags you can
start looking less tired and way more
desperate feel free to subscribe to this
YouTube channel and make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday sometime
click like if you enjoyed this makeup
tutorial video and would like me to do
more of them in the future let me know
some of your other bag ideas in the
comments down below and if you do any of
these bags or your own tag me on
Instagram I love see how creative and
better at drawing on your own face you
are than I am I got it I gotta wash my
face I don't know you reads that was me
trying to make me and not Gordon Ramsay
or Gary Busey the one my dad's gonna be
the most proud of